movie magic is what transports us to
unique worlds
and what brings magical characters to
life but have you ever wondered what
some
iconic screen moments would look like
without their visual effects
in this video we'll be taking you behind
the scenes of some of the most iconic
moments from your favorite movies and tv
shows
as much as we wish it was possible we
all know that humans
just can't fly and that the hulk just
doesn't exist
so how exactly do they make things like
superheroes and dinosaurs seem so real
it all happens in the editing room so
let's take a look at the behind the
scenes
of sets like maleficent the hunger games
and the avengers before all the cgi gets
added in
would you like to see is it safe from
the monstrous waves to the debris that
line the water during battle
pirates of the caribbean is full of
dashes of cgi and vfx editing that bring
the movie to life
but there's one specific moment from the
dead men tell no tales
that looks completely different behind
the scenes
the ghost shark scene featuring jack
sparrow and henry turner was filmed in
three different locations
an actual outdoor scenery a small water
tank
and an indoor set that was completely
blue screen
their rowboat was put on a gimbal so
that it would give the appearance that
they were
actually being attacked by sharks
angelina jolie put her all into the
making of maleficent but no matter how
much of a renegade she was on screen
her character would not have come to
life without the help of cgi
vfx and a very interesting machine
called a fork tuner
angelina was secured into a machine that
was controlled by other people
in order to get the motions right they
basically became puppets while filming
everything was completely blue screen
and her wings were added later on in
editing
the fairies in their small form were
also completely animated using a special
program
the actress's faces were processed so
that they'd be able to copy their exact
animation later on
it's probably no surprise that the
majority of this film is cgi and visual
effects
but what might surprise you is how baby
groot and rocket looked behind the
scenes
they were well basically not there both
characters are completely cgi
[Music]
during filming they'd have stuffed
animals and models as stand-ins so the
actors wouldn't be completely lost
beauty and the beast is where most
millennials got their first taste of
love
and romance but there's nothing lovely
and romantic about how beauty and the
beast looked behind the scenes
dan stevens didn't have a super
realistic beast costume
instead he wore a motion capture suit
the costume helped the editors use cgi
to make the beast come to life later on
the br guest scene was also
pretty lackluster behind the scenes
lumiere's grand performance was later
added in during
editing which left emma watson acting at
a fancy table alone
be our guest
avatar took 10 years to make so you can
only imagine
how much effort went into making
everything perfect
pandora itself was created completely
using green screen and vfx
but what's even more interesting is the
way the avatars were brought to life
the actors wore motion capture suits to
film their scenes and also had to get 3d
models of themselves done
so they could digitally make their
avatar based on their appearance later
on
looks like you this is your avatar now
jake
a whopping 300 shots were made using vfx
for divergent to produce the utopian
city we see in the film
that includes the dauntless train
jumping scene that catapults tris
into the world of danger it was actually
filmed in six different locations
with a platform that was completely made
later with visual effects
what you see in the film is actually the
editing team blending clips from
different locations to seamlessly fit
together
is it just me or are they trying to kill
us
taylor lautner didn't get a special wolf
suit instead he explored the magical
qualities grey spandex had to offer
and acted out his scenes with kristen
stewart to make sure she got the eye
contact right
then the vfx team did their magic and
created jacob's wolf form later on
they also used cgi to edit actress
mackenzie foy's face
on different age children after renesmee
was born
let's just be grateful we dodged them
using chuck esme
it was nessie who wanted me there nessie
you nicknamed my daughter after the walk
this monster
grey's anatomy may not have the need for
fancy editing like cgi and vfx
but their special effects and prop team
have their work cut out for them
the show brings to life some pretty
realistic medical procedures what you're
actually seeing is the actors working on
a dummy
full of animal intestines what the hell
is that thing oh that is a kidney in a
jar that's not a bear how did you get
that
in narnia characters like aslan were
completely computer generated
the actors would have to act out their
scenes alone to make it a little bit
easier they would have stand-ins where
the character would be
for aslin they even came up with a type
of model that could be controlled by
someone inside
that way they could get some of his
movements naturally
girl on fire catching fire fire was a
huge part of the hunger games franchise
and the majority of the time
it was added into shots using cgi and
vfx
well i was just hoping that i wouldn't
burn to death
for instance katniss's costumes both in
the first second
and third films were all thanks to the
editing team
and jennifer lawrence actually filmed
the scene where katniss runs from the
flames in the arena
completely without fire the dark forest
was huge in the wizard of oz spin-off
and it wouldn't have been able to come
alive without cgi
hate the dark forest hate the dark
forest during filming james franco
actually had to dodge poles meant to be
the tree branches
of the forest that were controlled by
the crew the china glass girl was also
completely done in the editing room for
the space scenery in the movie
almost everything was shot using a green
screen the filmmakers also had to find
the perfect way to make it seem like the
actors were acting without gravity
for the majority of the filming they
were strapped into a harness to give the
camera effect that they were floating in
space
the red queen might not have seemed as
malicious and intimidating if it wasn't
for her disproportioned head
or if it wasn't helena bonham carter i
used to have the white queen
now her head is so small tiny it's
purple of a head
but her body proportions were only
altered in editing
for filming she looked completely normal
there were also a bunch of other iconic
scenes that looked interesting behind
the scenes
welcome to jurassic world jurassic world
may have had its audiences believing
that dinosaurs might one day roam the
earth again
but for a lot of the filming no type of
dinosaur
fake or real was even present instead
the actors would perform the scene while
being mindful of the markers that told
them where the dinosaurs were meant to
be
if the actor had a scene where they were
interacting with the dinosaur
they would have people dress up in fake
dinosaur heads and act as a stand-in
the most impressive part of the avengers
end game is probably how well they made
the hulk scenes come to life
mark ruffalo wore a special motion suit
and headpiece while acting
so that they'd later be able to
transform him and his facial features
into the hero put the brains and the bra
together
and now look at me best of both worlds
another notable cgi moment is when they
had to actually use programs to create
captain marvel's hair
the iconic moment that black panther
rose from the fire and ashes
to show everyone he was still alive i am
not dead
is probably something i and a lot of
other marvel fans
will never forget but behind the scenes
all chadwick boseman had to do
was step onto some foam blocks and the
rest was
all edited in the only character in the
jungle book who wasn't the product of
cgi
or vfx was mowgli the rest of his jungle
friends were made with cgi
the actor had fake animals on set to
help him imagine the scene
and deliver his lines better the
majority of the jungle was
also completely done using cgi
relax kid no need to get worked up okay
daenerys flying her dragon is nothing
short of magical
but behind the scenes it was a little
less
graceful they had amelia clark climb up
on an animatronic dragon
surrounded by a green screen that would
mimic the movements of flying
the editor's job was to bring all of
that to life
sorry to say folks but gollum really
doesn't exist
not even behind the scenes unless you
count his actor
andy circus dressed up in a motion suit
saying
but the credit all goes to the visual
effects team who brought the character
to life
perfectly are we really surprised that a
portion of this film was spent on a
yacht
all these scenes were actually filmed in
a studio with green screens
the iconic scene where the yacht is
taken over by some pretty intense waves
wouldn't have been possible without cgi
and visual effects either
[Music]
some of these scenarios look nothing
like the final product we saw on screen
it makes you realize that acting is a
lot more than just
reading off of a script and that a
film's editing and special effects team
deserves way more credit than they get
what behind the scenes moment was the
most shocking for you don't forget to
hit that subscribe button
and give this video a huge thumbs up for
movie magic
[Music]
you